they can see the russian positions from
this front line and they watch nervously
waiting for the next exchange of fire
it happens every day one side attacks
the other responds and so on
it is a continuous circle that sums up
the fighting in this part of ukraine
both sides are dug in and at the moment
going nowhere
so you're regularly hitting each other
are you
talk
but little
this is a forward artillery camp on the
southern front captured from the
russians when the ukrainians pushed them
back there are small bases like this
dotted all along the fields here
it's pretty basic in camp the soldiers
wear a mishmash of kit and you can
understand why they are desperate for
more advanced weapons
this is where you come when they start
shelling
it's very small
if the russians start bombing you this
is all the protection you've got right
they say the dogs sense incoming rockets
before they do and so they keep them in
the camp as a sort of early warning
system
it might be nonsense but superstitions
run high on the front line and they
insist the dogs keep them safe
anything for the upper hand in this
attritional war
just the other side of a field behind is
a village that has been liberated from
the russians we're not allowed to name
it
the ukrainian flag is flying again at
the crossroads placed deliberately so it
can be seen from the russian positions
there are a few other signs of life
just as we're about to leave though an
elderly woman appears from her house
this is svetlana one of only three
people still here she's with her husband
[Music]
[Music]
it's nothing more than a hole in the
ground it's dark and very cramped but
when the fighting gets heavy this is all
the protection that the elderly couple
have
she gives the ukrainian soldiers some
fresh milk but that small moment of
kindness is interrupted by reality
as the thud of artillery starts around
us
and then they tell us to run
relentless
bungle sky news in southern ukraine